[Music]
Sam Jackson plays Nick Fury you're in
America and you guys got close when you
were shooting you became friends uh well
Sam and I have always been friends it's
just funny because in this movie it's
the first time we were opposite each
other and I had my goatee he had his
goatee and he just looked like my dad so
I called him dad the entire movie like
there's this whole subplot I put in
there where Nick Fury is the Falcons dad
right so every time he would come on set
I go ahead yeah you did have a similar
look in this movie or did that yeah now
did you did you so angry
he's angry he doesn't look like he finds
your joke I'm using it oh he's just
angry about breakfast he's just angry
who scrambled my eggs angry for no
reason I think we have a picture here
you as Falcon I think we have it that's
me kid that's look at that that's really
me flying that's really you find yang's
and everything now I'm getting the
Victoria Secret Angel vibe when I see
that which is not a bad thing it's very
sexy I don't know they all do really
well for themselves you is it it's not
CGI they actually had you flying is I
mean there's some CGI but the wings are
CGI you have to know the hardest-working
people in Hollywood hands down I don't
care what anybody says is a flying
superhero so god bless those Victoria's
Secret models because they work really
hard I wish there was a way I could
thank them over and over again harnesses
is that right they had you in policing
yeah yeah no I was a four point harness
system is basically they put you in a
girdle for a man with thigh garters and
and they put four picks on you with the
string so they can make you do that they
can make you do that they can make you
do that yeah they can put you on a track
and make you go forward bring you back
they can make you go up in a loop
they can do all kind of stuff it's crazy
it's really something you would do at
Six Flags adventure it sounds like a
like it would be fun it's a be pretty
it's fun pretty hardcore it's pretty
hardcore but at the same time if you're
a like a nauseous kind of guy you can't
do it
but you know I'm kind of OG Bobby
Johnson so I can go straight in
yeah and you learned a lot about you
studied Falcons is that right to prepare
for being Falcon you studied Falcons
let's just say I am a Falcon connoisseur
now Falcon Crest is my favorite TV show
and I learned a falcon call you earned a
falcon call yeah
can we hear it you want to hear sure
don't get scared
alright that won't last time I was here
you got scared alright yeah I'll just
run away if I could
good good good I'm gonna grab you
alright
[Applause]
I'm pretty good it was incredible okay
you run the risk of internal damage is
incredible you're bleeding out of your
ears it's kind of like a mating call
it's weird yeah you're gonna wear some
really interesting people than real
especially in LA just if we're